Welcome everyone and thank you for
coming to this a forum this morning.
Uh,
I am David Cameron,
dean of the Faculty of Arts and Science
at the University of Toronto.
Let me begin by saying,
uh,
that we acknowledge this land on which
the University of Toronto operates for
thousands of years.
That has been the traditional land of
the Huron wind at the Seneca and most
recently the mississaugas of the credit
river.
Today.
This meeting place is still the home to
many indigenous people from across
turtle island and we are grateful for
the opportunity to live and work on this
lab.
The goal of today's forum is to help the
university community and interested
members of our society to understand the
gender provisions and implications of
Bill [inaudible] and the Ontario Human
Rights Code.
The Federal Bill See 16 passed yesterday
as it happens in the House of Commons.
As most of you will know,
this matter has been a subject of
intense controversy within the
university and beyond.
Our aim in holding the form is to
provide the opportunity for academic
discussion of the matter and a serious
exploration of the issues in play.
We ask everyone to engage with the
issues and with one another in a spirit
of civility and respect,
upholding in the words of the
university's policy on the disruption of
meetings,
the principles of freedom of speech and
the freedom of individuals and groups to
be free of physical intimidation and
harassment.
Today's forum is being live streamed.
Professor Mayo,
Moran Chair and moderator will be
outlining the procedures and the format,
uh,
shortly.
She's just here in the seat in front of
me.
Uh,
but first I'd like to introduce the
panelists for the academic discussion.
Dr Mary Bryson on my far left is a
senior associate dean administration,
Faculty Affairs and Innovation and
Professor Department of Language and
literacy education in the Faculty of
Education at the University of British
Columbia,
Dr Bryson chairs,
the UBC vice-presidential trends to
spirit and gender diversity task force.
And as a member of the World
Professional Association for the
transgender health global education
initiative.
They're the recipient of multiple awards
for their entire interdisciplinary
scholarship,
including most recently the American
Educational Research Association,
Significant Body of Research Award and a
senior fellowship at Stanford
University's Clayman Institute for
Gender Research at present,
uh,
their,
their CIA,
CIA hr funded cancer's margins project
is the first nationwide Canadian
research study designed to advance our
understanding of how sexuality and
gender shape cancer health knowledge
access and its mobilization in health
and in treatment decision making.
That's both medically and culturally
competent.
Brenda cossman in the middle is a
professor of law and the director of the
bottom center for sexual diversity
studies at the University of Toronto.
She is a fellow of the Royal Society of
Canada and the recipient of the Mandela
metal awarded by the Attorney General of
Ontario for contributions to letters and
law professor of crossman's teaching and
scholarly interests include family law,
law and sexuality,
human rights,
censorship and freedom of expression.
Her book,
sexual citizens.
The legal and cultural regulation of sex
and belonging was published by Stanford
University press in 2007.
Professor Cossman,
uh,
other publications include the
coauthored bad attitudes on trial,
pornography,
feminism and the Butler decision and
censorship in the arts.
Jordan Peterson and meet my immediate
left is a professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto and a clinical
psychologist with his students and
colleagues.
Professor Peterson has published more
than a hundred scientific papers on a
wide range of topics in social
psychology.
He's the author of maps of meaning,
the architecture of belief,
a book which also forms the basis of one
of his,
uh,
u of t classes.
He's presented many of his lectures
online,
including the virtue of necessity.
More recently,
he has released the three part online
series entitled Professor Against
Political Correctness.
This morning's forum will be moderated
by Professor Mayo Moran,
the provost and Vice Chancellor of the
Trinity College and a law professor and
former dean of the u of t law school.
She writes about legal theory and
problems of responsibility,
including a book on the reasonable
person published by Oxford University
press.
She is currently writing about the
problem of the past for Provost Moran
has done policy work on issues ranging
from how to protect public participation
in policy debates to accessibility,
sexual violence and residential schools.
She teaches a course called 10 cases
about the,
uh,
10 cases that change the world.
It's of course I'd like to take that was
recently listed by Maclean's magazine as
one of u of t's cool courses.
I thought.
Cool is old,
old fashioned now,
but they,
uh,
the Faculty of Arts and science at the
University of Toronto in is very
grateful to all of the panelists for
agreeing to take part in this morning's
forum.
And I would like now to call on
Professor Moron to briefly describe the
format of today's
discussion.
Professor,
thank you very much Dean Cameron and
welcome to everyone.
I have a little bit of Laryngitis,
so please excuse me if my voice isn't as
strong as usual.
Um,
this forum,
as you know,
uh,
today is designed as an academic
discussion as Dean Cameron said on
issues arising out of the current debate
on the provisions of Bill See 16 and the
gender provisions of the Ontario Human
Rights Code.
Okay.
Critically examining and in our hope
illuminating the great policy issues of
the day is a vital role for the
university.
The university is uniquely well situated
because within the confines of the
university we have people as students
would know,
who are experts on every possible topic
and who have devoted their lives to
understanding those topics.
So the university is probably the best
possible place,
uh,
to debate the great issues of the day,
the issues that are causing controversy
and discussion and to critically
examine,
uh,
the public arguments in light of fact
and reason.
And that is the spirit in which we
gather here today.
So thank you for joining us and thank
you to our panelists.
Um,
in,
in doing that,
in pursuing that mission,
as Dean Cameron said,
uh,
we seek to further at the twin,
um,
principles of the University of open
dialogue and also tolerance.
We acknowledge of course that sometimes
those principles are intention with each
other.
But respect for both is absolutely
critical to the mission of the
university.
I would like to begin by acknowledging
that the subject matter that we're
discussing today may be difficult and
that audience members and indeed
participants will have strong feelings
about the subject matter that we're
discussing.
Um,
we have arranged for support for anyone
who would like it just outside the room
and bearing in mind the nature of the
discussion that we're having and our
objectives,
which are two aluminate discuss and
understand.
I would ask that members of the
audience,
even if you don't agree with some of the
speakers to please allow them to voice
their opinions.
There will be time for questions at the
end.
Okay.
I now like to just say a couple of
things about how we plan to,
um,
uh,
how we constructed the forum,
which we did a in dialogue with the
participants.
Um,
so we're going to begin by,
um,
having,
it'll be hundred minutes long and the
first segment we'll discuss the
provisions of bill.
See 16 in the Ontario Human Rights Code
and we'll focus especially on freedom of
expression and human rights law.
In that first segment,
we will begin with Professor Peterson
who will speak for 10 minutes followed
by Professor Cossman who will speak for
10 minutes and we do have a timekeeper.
Can you wave your hand?
There we go.
Uh,
just to ensure we're trying to make
sure,
obviously we know there's lots to say on
these topics.
We're going to try to make sure that
we've divided the time up and allocated
it as fairly as possible.
In the second segment of this
discussion,
we're again focusing on [inaudible] on
the Ontario human rights code w we'll
focus more on academic freedom,
gender diversity and the implications
for scholarship and teaching in that
segment.
Professor Peterson will again begin and
professor Bryson will follow and they
will have 10 minutes each.
Following that,
I will have a short a period to just ask
some clarifying questions of the
speakers and I've agreed with the
speaker so we'll keep our answers to
three minutes each.
I won't ask questions that are longer
than three minutes.
Just again in an effort to ensure that
we have as much opportunity to air some
of the issues that people might be
thinking about as possible.
Following that,
we'll have 30 minutes for questions from
the audience.
You can see up here that you can email
questions to that email address.
If you don't have email here.
Um,
we have pencil and paper and people will
go around and gather questions and then
we'll have some people curate the
questions and bring them back to me and
I will ask them again in an effort to
get as many of the issues as possible on
the table.
And the speakers have all agreed kindly.
Again,
they'll keep their answers to three
minutes each.
So thank you all very much.
Um,
and with that,
um,
I would like to begin and uh,
I will ask a professor Peterson to
start.
Thank you.
Thanks.
So,
um,
I'd like if you wouldn't mind,
I'd like the audience to do something
with me.
The first thing I'd like them to do if
you would,
is if all the women in the audience
would stand up.
That would be much appreciated.
Okay.
Now,
thank you very much.
Now perhaps all the men would stand up.
Okay,
good.
Sorry,
I did a rough count when I came in here
and I might be out,
but I'm not out by March.
I think it's about two to one males in
here.
And I thought I'd point that out because
it's,
it's kind of interesting to me because
I'm a personality psychologist and this
debate is about ideas and there's a
personality trait called openness,
which is associated with intellect and
creativity and there are pronounced
gender differences in openness such that
men are higher and intellect,
which encompasses interest in ideas and
women are hiring is theoretics which
encompasses interest in while in art and
literature and that sort of thing.
And it's partly for that reason that men
read more nonfiction and women read more
fiction.
And I just wanted to point out that
there was a natural gender divide that
occurred automatically and without
compulsion in this particular case,
in the case of this debate and that the
more our society,
uh,
enforces,
it's increasingly absurd demands for
equity upon everyone,
the less likely it is that such natural
divisions will be able to manifest them
in ours,
manifest themselves in our society,
in keeping with the pronounced in deep
differences between the genders.
So I just thought that makes an
interesting initial,
uh,
what would you call it?
Real world demonstration.
So,
okay.
So about two months ago made these
videos,
um,
I did it because I was trying to
articulate my concerns.
Um,
um,
for a variety of reasons.
I've been keeping an eye on political
correctness for a long time and I was
also very upset with the human resources
and Equity Department's decision to make
antiracism so-called antiracism and
antibiose training mandatory for their
staff,
which I regard as an unacceptable
intrusion into their staffs,
right to their political opinion,
as well as noting that there's
absolutely no evidence whatsoever that
mandatory anti racism and anti bias
training has,
it's has the impact that is claimed.
In fact,
the empirical evidence suggests quite
the contrary when you mandate that sort
of thing,
you actually make more people more
prejudiced.
It's also based on what I would say is a
rather pernicious form of pseudo science
that's being promoted by social
psychologists to group that I have a
fair bit of trouble with and that's been
transformed into a kind of educational
fascism that has no grounding whatsoever
in the empirical literature.
Now,
what happened as a consequence of making
these videos was,
um,
was really quite unexpected to me.
There.
We've,
we've been trying to keep count,
there's been 140 print articles
published about this,
whatever this is in the last two months.
And then dozens and dozens of,
of youtube videos and television
interviews and radio interviews and
demonstrations.
Millions of people have been tuning into
this online.
And so obviously something's up and I
can tell you that what's up isn't only a
discussion about bill see 16 and about
gendered pronouns.
You know,
sometimes when you're having a debate or
discussion with someone that you love
and you're having a little argument
about something like who's going to do
the dishes or something like that.
Or you know how it,
especially if you haven't been getting
along very well with that person,
you know how the discussion starts with
something specific and then you start
trading all the things that it might be
about until you're arguing about,
you know,
the way that you behaved on your third
date,
you know,
10 years ago.
And the whole underlying unresolved
chaos of your relationship emerges
through the little portal that was
defined by the argument,
you know,
well that's what this is about.
So what,
what the Hell's going on here?
Exactly.
And why are we,
are we damn near at each other's
throats?
Look at what happened in the United
States a week and a half ago.
There's been things to talk about here
in,
I started to try to talk about the men.
I would say that my freedom to do so was
rapidly infringed upon.
My career was put at risk.
And,
and I find this absolutely unacceptable
because I am trying to sort this out and
believe me,
you know what you call people,
you can't talk to
enemies.
And if we want to divide our society
into armed camps of enmity,
all we have to do is keep doing what
we're doing.
And I would recommend that we don't do
this.
I've studied authoritarianism for a very
long time.
I know what happens when things get out
of control and it can happen
extraordinarily rapidly.
And I would say we're on the cusp of
that.
And so we need to start talking and
listening.
And when you talk,
it doesn't mean you're right.
It doesn't mean you're correct,
right?
It means you're trying to articulate and
formulate your thoughts,
like the bone headed more on that you
are,
and you're going to stumble around
idiotically because what the hell do you
know?
You're full of biases and you're
ignorant than you can't speak very well
and you're over emotional and you know
you've got just problems that you can
hardly even imagine that are interfering
with your ability to state something
clear.
And so what you do is you do your best
to say what you mean and then you listen
to other people tell you why you're a
blithering idiot.
And hopefully you can correct yourself
to some degree as a consequence of
listening to them.
And you see that's what free speech is
about because you have to,
it,
it isn't just the people can,
can organize themselves and their
societies by thinking you can't do that
because there's only one of you.
What you have to do is you have to
articulate your thoughts in a public
forum so that other people can attack
you and hopefully in a corrective
manner.
And then you want to,
you know,
step back a little bit and think,
okay,
well you know I was a little arrogant
there and I was a little over emotional
there and I didn't get that quite right.
And maybe I'm outright biased on that
front.
And you,
you want to correct what you say because
then you correct how you are and then
you correct how you act in life and then
you correct your society.
And to the degree that we limit free
freedom of expression,
we put all of that at risk.
You know,
I'm a clinical psychologist and one of
the things,
there's two things that we kind of know
about why clinical psychology works and
one is that people get stronger if they
voluntarily expose themselves to things
they're afraid of and that they're
disgusted by.
It's like a,
it's a hallmark of clinical
psychotherapy.
And I would say it's also the defining
characteristic of,
of appropriate human adaptation,
right?
Is that you have to confront the chaotic
things that you don't understand and
then learn to master them and articulate
them.
And the other is that clinical
psychotherapy works because people can
come say into my office and they can say
whatever they have to say,
no matter how incoherent it is or how
psychotic it is or,
or how overbearing it is or confused or
jumbled.
And sometimes it takes my clients months
or years of continual conversation just
to start to untie the hundreds of
thousands of knots that have been badly
tied in their minds.
So,
and that's partly why I don't believe
that freedom of speech is just another
value.
I think that's preposterous.
I think that if you claim that,
then you know nothing about Western
civilization and history is freedom of
speech is not just another principle.
It's the mechanism by which we keep our
psyches and our society's organized.
And we have to be unbelievably careful
about in infringing upon that because
we're infringing upon the process by
which we keep chaos and order balanced,
you know?
And,
and if chaos and order go out of
balance,
then then then,
then all hell breaks loose and the
situation is not good.
And we've seen that happen many,
many times in the 20th century.
Right.
Since the late 18 hundreds our
societies,
western societies have been careening
madly between the hyper repressive order
of the radical right and the absolute
devouring chaos of the radical left.
We've become unmoored.
We've lost our bearings and the only
thing that can possibly save us from
continuing to do exactly that is the
dialogue of exactly the sort that I'm,
I'm,
I'm describing at the moment and what
we're attempting to do today in this
forum.
Thank God the university agreed to have
this debate,
you know,
because there's things to talk about and
if we don't talk about them,
then we're going to fight.
Well,
what is this all about?
I can list you some of the things that
it's about,
it's about inclusion versus bigotry and
prejudice,
right?
It's about the left wing versus the
right wing.
It's about who's free to choose their
language and what,
what,
what elements of respect that you're due
to people who are different than you say
with regards to Pronoun Use are chosen
names.
It's about whether the subject of or the
object of is going to take precedence
because implicit in bill [inaudible] 16
and I'm telling you there's an assault
on the idea of objectivity itself,
an assault on the idea of biology itself
and if the university thinks that the
sciences are going to be immune from the
ideological doctrine that's embedded in
these,
in these pieces of legislation,
they better think again because there
there is trouble coming.
I know that [inaudible] already has an
anti psychiatry program and we noticed
the Ken Zucker got hounded out of this
job just a few years ago even though he
was an entirely credible scientist and
clinician.
So it's about constructionism,
social constructionism versus positivism
versus pragmatism and there's,
there's a mother versus father thing
going on here too and you know,
you kind of saw that with Hillary
Clinton versus Donald Trump.
I would say that was the overprotective
devouring mother versus the tyrannical
father,
which is not a good,
that's not a good narrative from a
mythological perspective.
It's about also the adversarial spirit I
would say versus the logos.
That's at the deepest possible level of
analysis than the adversarial spirit is
the spirit declaimed.
What I think right now is correct above
all else and I have nothing whatsoever
to learn versus the logos and the logos
is a very complex,
uh,
idea and maybe the deepest idea of,
of humanity.
I would say certainly the deepest idea
of western civilization.
And that's that the proper citizen is
the person who embodies truth in speech
and attempts to act it out.
And that also includes listening because
listening is part of communicative
intent.
And I think at the moment that we're in,
we're embroiled in a war on every single
one of those dimensions and several
others that I haven't had time to list.
And the,
the evidence that we're in that sort of
war is precisely the fact that this is
attracted so much attention.
I mean,
I just sat at my bloody office at home
and threw up a couple of amateurish
videos,
more or less attempting to articulate my
feelings about a couple of policies and
it's like all hell broke loose and why?
Well,
because that hail is right underneath
the surface.
I think to stop there,
but you're right.
I'm done.
[inaudible]
thank you.
Thank you,
Professor Moran.
Provost Moran.
Um,
I'd like to start by saying that I'm
delighted to be here today except that
I'm not,
and I'd like to start by saying how much
I support and respect all those faculty,
staff and students who are boycotting
today's event.
I think that that is also a very
important form of speech.
The a couple of days ago,
um,
the Oxford English dictionary announced
the word of the year and it's post
truth.
It's relating to or denoting
circumstances in which objective facts
are less influential in shaping public
opinion than appeals to emotion and
personal belief.
So I worry about the ways that post post
truth claims have been affecting public
discussions around bill see 16 around
the Ontario human rights code and around
freedom of expression.
There have been some profound,
okay,
it's not part of my time,
that little correction.
There've been some profound
misunderstandings.
I'm circulating about the law and I'm
here today as a lawyer,
as a law professor,
as a civil libertarian,
as an expert in equality rights and
freedom of expression to try to correct
those misunderstandings.
So let's start with bill [inaudible] 16
which passed third reading yesterday in
the house.
It's the proposed federal legislation
that does three things.
First,
it adds gender identity and expression
to the Canadian human rights code.
It will prevent the Canadian government,
federal agencies and businesses within
federal jurisdiction,
which are quite limited banks,
telecoms,
airlines from discriminating on the
basis of gender identity and expression.
This is hardly unprecedented.
Indeed.
The federal government is late to this
game.
I'm starting in 2002 and moving forward.
The Northwest Territory's Manitoba,
Ontario,
Nova Scotia,
Prince Edward Island,
Newfoundlands,
Saskatchewan,
Alberta,
Quebec,
British Columbia have already passed
these protections.
Ontario has had these since 2002 the
federal government here is simply
playing catchup.
There's absolutely nothing unprecedented
in this.
Number two,
Bill See,
16 adds gender identity and gender
expression to provisions in the criminal
code that define an identifiable group
for the purposes of advocating genocide.
The public incitement of hatred and the
willful promotion of hatred.
So how might these provisions affect the
use of pronouns and do these provisions
in any way criminalize the use or misuse
of pronouns,
not even close.
First,
it is absolutely not advocating
genocide.
Now the last one wants to start talking
about we should kill all the axes then
that's advocating genocide,
but pronoun use nowhere.
Close public incitement of hatred.
Well,
the provisions of the Criminal Code
requires that the incitement is likely
to lead to a breach of the peace.
Now,
does that sound subjective?
Well,
the Supreme Court of Canada has said
there's a very clear,
there's a very clear definition.
The threshold is violence.
In fact,
there has to be personal violence.
It is an extremely high threshold,
and again,
the misuse of pronouns doesn't come
anywhere close.
Finally,
the willful promotion of hatred,
so called hate speech provisions now
hates be provisions in the criminal code
have a very,
very high threshold.
The Supreme Court of Canada has
repeatedly defined hate speech as only
including the most extreme forms of
speech the court has said over and over
again.
And I quote it is quote the unusually
strong and deep felt emotions of
vilification and detestation the court
has said it is not disdain,
it is not dislike,
it is not offense plus something that's
often lost.
Hate speech.
Criminal charges cannot be laid without
the approval of the attorney general.
So this is a high threshold.
They are very difficult charges to
bring.
Third Bill,
see 16 adds gender identity and
expression to the provisions of the
criminal code that deal with sentencing
for hate crimes.
Now here under this particular section
seven 18 to a one w we tend to be
concerned about numbers,
um,
evidence that an offense is motivated by
bias,
prejudice or hatred can be taken into
account.
In sentencing,
we already take a range of things into
account,
race,
national and ethnic origin,
religion,
sex,
age and others.
So now evidence of hatred on the basis
of gender identity and expression could
be taken into account.
It's important to emphasize section
seven 18 does not create any new
offenses.
It simply means that any existing
offense in the criminal code like
assault or sexual assault or murder,
if it's motivated by hatred,
could be given an increased sense.
This has no impact on pronouns unless of
course,
and accused was misusing pronouns while
assaulting sexually assaulting or
murdering someone.
In other words,
there's nothing in Bilski 16 that comes
close to criminalizing the misuse of
pronouns.
Nothing,
not hate speech,
not hate crime.
Now let's look at the Ontario Human
Rights Code.
So the Ontario Human Rights Code is a
provincial law that protects individuals
from discrimination in housing,
Employment Services,
vocational associations and contracts.
It's not constitutional law,
which limits government action.
It's not criminal law where the state
prosecutes individuals and sends them to
jail.
It's a type of civil law where private
individuals can sue one another.
Um,
and the,
the remedy is generally damages.
The Ontario Human Rights Code was first
passed in 1962.
It protects people from all kinds of
discrimination.
It protects people from being fired on
the basis of their race or it protects
people from being denied housing on the
basis of their religion or it protects
people from being called the n word or
any other racial epithet in the delivery
of services like a university classroom.
Since 2012 the Ontario Human Rights Code
has prohibited discrimination and
harassment on the basis of gender
identity and expression.
It prevents discrimination and
harassment against Trans and gender non
binary individuals in employment,
housing and services.
So what does this require in relation to
pronouns?
According to the Ontario Human Rights
Commission's policy section 7.4,
it specifically said that refusing to
refer to a person by their self
identified name or proper Pronoun could
constitute gender based harassment.
And as a result of some q and a's that
were released yesterday by the
commission,
uh,
clarifying this question of Gender
Pronoun use,
um,
uh,
they stated the following,
refusing to refer to a trans person by
their chosen name and a personal pronoun
that matches their gender identity or
purposely misgendering will likely be
discrimination when it takes place in a
social arena.
Covered by the code,
including employment,
housing services like education,
but about gender neutral pronouns.
Well,
the commission has said the Ontario
Human Rights Code does not require any
particular gender neutral pronoun.
If in doubt,
ask the person how they wish to be
addressed.
Use they if you don't know or simply use
their chosen name.
So what it seems to require is the use
of he,
she or they.
And if you don't like that,
then you can always just use their name.
There is no question of the 31 flavors
that has been put out there that is
somehow being mandated.
Um,
this is about he,
she,
they,
or if you don't like it,
use a person's name.
Some questions have arisen about this.
Is this the first time that a law has
decided what we must say as opposed to
what we cannot say?
No,
not at all.
Not even close.
It's not uncommon for the law to require
expression.
Bilingual labeling requirements on food
packaging,
health warnings on cigarette packages,
the oath of allegiance to the queen that
must be sworn at citizenship.
Ship ceremonies.
Not only is forced expression,
not new,
there's an entire chapter dedicated to
it in Peter Hogg's constitutional law of
Canada.
Now,
for those of you who don't know Peter
Hog is in law,
we usually deal with,
we refer to him in a hushed voice.
He is the leading authoritative,
it is the leading authoritative texts in
Canadian constitutional law by Canada's
preeminent constitutional scholar and
lawyer.
Okay,
so is it constitutional?
Now,
are these requirements around pronouns
constitutional?
Does the requirement to not miss gender?
The pronouns violate freedom of
expression under section two B of the
Canadian Charter of rights and freedoms?
Probably a does.
The Supreme Court of Canada says any
restriction on speech is a prime fascia
violation of section two b.
But the thing is that's not the end of
the story.
The charter rights are not absolute.
No charter rights are absolute.
There's this whole other section in the
charter called section one which says
that all rights and freedoms are subject
to reasonable limits as are demonstrably
justifiable in a free and democratic
society.
The Supreme Court of Canada has
developed a very complex test through
which it balances rights.
On the one hand and reasonable limits on
the other.
This is what the Supreme Court of Canada
does in charter cases.
And the Supreme Court of Canada has on
numerous occasions considered whether
restrictions on speech contained in
human rights codes are constitutional.
It has consistently,
and I have to emphasize consistently
held that although any speech
restrictions that are contained in a
human rights code may violate section
two B of the charter.
They are a reasonable limit within the
meaning of section one.
They held this in the case of Ross in
the case of Taylor and most recently,
unanimously by the court in 2013.
Um,
I have a little thing then about why all
this matters and I'm out of time.
But why it all matters is um,
because people matter and I worry that
we've moved into a place now a kind of
not only a post truth politics,
but a kind of post empathy politics
where we no longer seem to care about
people.
And this at the end of the day is about
It's about trans and gender non binary
people.
These are our children,
our siblings,
our nieces,
our nephews.
These are our friends,
our neighbors,
our colleagues,
our lawyers are carpenters and our
teachers.
How bloody hard is it to simply treat
these people with respect and dignity?
Because all this is about
all human rights are about,
is respect and dignity.
And if he could throw in a little
kindness on the top,
that would be even better.
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
Uh,
professor Cossman and now we will go
back.
So what number?
I said we're after we do the first
section.
We're going to go back to Professor
Peterson.
And on this section we're going to focus
a little bit more on academic freedom,
gender diversity in some of the
implications for scholarship and
teaching.
Um,
so professor Peterson,
I didn't bite you to go first again,
10 minutes.
We'll have our,
our time,
our excellent timekeeper back there.
Thank you.
So I'm gonna read you something that a
graduate student sent me from the
University of Toronto the other day.
And I can also tell you that I've
received hundreds of letters like this
today.
I had a tutorial at the University of
Toronto where I talked about Jordan
Peterson and issues of personal
identity,
legally sanctioned identity categories,
et cetera.
I brought up a video of a tall white man
in his thirties who asked students out
of university how they'd react if he
told them.
He identified as a woman,
as black,
as short and as five years old.
Spoiler alert.
Students in the video resists some of
the later categories a bit better,
mostly accepting still students were not
engaging in discussion.
I asked them why one said it was because
she was worried to share her opinion for
fear of being singled out or saying
something offensive.
I asked who else was not speaking for
that reason.
The whole class put their hands up.
That was shocking to me.
I encouraged them to speak despite their
worries and they gave me some good
feedback on how to make it easier for
them to do so.
For instance,
by working in pairs and being assigned
an opinion so that they didn't have to
be responsible for it or feel bad for
defending it.
No participation.
Why
they weren't on interested.
They were afraid to speak their minds.
The PC police are in your heads.
He just turned the lawyer's opinion.
I have many lawyers opinions.
By the way.
I'll start with lawyer one who was the
counsel to several prime ministers.
He talked to me about the human rights
tribunal cause I went and saw him two
weeks after this all started.
Human Rights Tribunal is a kangaroo
court in my opinion,
and it should be abolished as fast as
possible.
It's one of the many institutions in
Canada that pose a threat to your,
to your freedom that that is almost
unimaginable proportions.
Here's what this top lawyer told me.
If I'm taking in front of the human
rights tribunal and will cost me
$250,000 I will pay the legal costs for
my opponents and I will lose.
He said,
go back to your safe little life and
shut your mouth.
Second lawyer told me my critique of the
Ontario Human Rights Commission is spot
on and absent the charter of rights and
freedoms,
which has these contradictions built
into it that you just heard described.
Much of what I was saying was illegal
and has been illegal since 2012 lawyer
three told me that if I breached a
tribunal order,
so imagine I was taken in front of the
human rights tribunal and I was fine and
then I refused to pay the fine,
which I've stated that I would do that
equals contempt of court,
which inevitably means jail until the
contempt is purged.
He told me the social justice tribunals,
and that's the technical name of these
essentially extra judicial bodies in
Ontario,
by the way,
the social justice tribunals.
So the PC authoritarian types aren't
even trying to hide their terminology
anymore.
The social justice tribunals and the
sjws social justice warriors who staff
them have a robe nature.
They can search your house without a
warrant.
They can use secret hearings.
There are no rules of evidence and the
judges are unaccountable.
Your worst fears of the effect of a
poorly written law will manifest in that
environment.
The sjw say only the worst of the worst.
We'll get punished.
Think again with them at the helm.
Anything can and does happen,
but those are legal opinions.
Let's,
let's look at a real world case.
Let's look at what happened when I made
my videos.
Let's look at how the university
responded because I can tell you in the
video,
I said,
look,
what I'm doing is probably illegal and
worse,
my employer is legally responsible for
it because that's built in.
That's built into the codes as well.
So by the way,
if you're an employer,
you're responsible for everything that
your employees say and everything that
anybody interprets what they said as
being,
whether it's unintentional or
intentional,
whether or not a complaint has been
made.
So just think about that.
Anyways,
October 3rd the university said like all
members of the university community,
I have an obligation to comply with the
law,
including the provisions of the Ontario
Human Rights Code,
their policy with regards to workplace
harassment,
which the university implied that I was
engaging in engaging in a course of
vexatious comment or conduct where the
course of comment or conduct is known or
ought reasonably be known to be
unwelcome.
That was the October 3rd letter,
which was sent to me within one week of
posting my videos.
And it was the first.
So what happened?
Essentially it was the university
reviewed what I had done and then they
reviewed the policies as laid out on the
Ontario Human Rights Commission website.
Where are you guys can all go read them
by the way.
And then you can decide if,
if,
if the legal information that you were
just provided with it,
with his in any degree whatsoever
accurate.
Because I would say it isn't,
um,
the university reviewed my videos and
they decided that what I said was true.
They decided that the video I made was
probably illegal and if they were
responsible for it.
And so in an attempt to distance
themselves from me under counsel from
their legal people and believe me the
university has good legal people,
they sent me a warning and this is what
happens if you want a discipline and
recalcitrant employee essentially what,
so that you don't have to bear legal
responsibility for their acts.
You send them a warning to show that
you're not in favor of what they're
doing.
Then if they continue,
you send them another warning and then
if they continue you send them a third
warning.
And after the third warning you can take
further steps.
Now I pointed out to the university at
one point when when,
um,
we were discussing how this forum was
going to proceed,
that perhaps it would be in their best
interests to not support the people who
are trying to stop me from talking,
but instead to support me legally and if
necessary,
to take this all the way to the supreme
court.
And the university said categorically
that they would not do that.
So I would say when it comes to the
contradictory provisions that are in the
Canadian Charter of rights and freedoms,
and so we might say roughly equality
versus freedom of speech,
the university decided which side
they're going to go down on.
And you know,
people tell you all the time,
okay,
that this has to do with compassion.
You know,
and it's obviously the case that all of
the compassion in this disgust is
discussion is on the side of the people
who are,
um,
any encouraging their listeners to play
victim and perpetrator.
And I can tell you as a
psychoanalytically oriented
psychologists that there's nothing more
horrible for children and developing
people than an excessive compassion,
right?
That's the standard Friday and devouring
mother.
And if you want a little archetype,
uh,
to go along with that,
I suppose most of you have seen,
um,
the little mermaid.
You Remember Ursula?
Ursula wants to put King Poseidon's soul
in a little jar in her collection and
she wants to take away Ariel's voice so
she can't establish herself as a
conscious being in the world.
And I would suggest very strongly that
all these people that continually talk
to you about compassion do not in the
least have your best interests in mind.
And there are far more virtues and
values than an excessive pity for
people.
You know,
you don't want a pitty your children
even.
You want to encourage them to develop
and strong and in a strong and
forthright manner so that they can go
out and take on the world.
And an excess of compassion just to
ensures that when they're 40 they're
going to be living in your basement
plotting evil routines about the world
because their ability to manifest
themselves as successful beings has been
absolutely compromised.
And I think that we're seeing this
played out.
We're busy,
we're seeing this played out in society
and,
and I think it's absolutely horrifying.
So on October 18th the university
mentioned to me in another warning
letter that if personal pronouns are
being used,
the refusal to use the personal pronoun
that is an expression of the person's
gender identity can constitute
discrimination.
So now you see what's happened is that I
haven't refused to use someone's
gendered gender neutral pronouns I said
that I would refuse.
So it's not even the refusal itself
that's producing the letters.
It's my declared intent to engage in the
refusal.
And as far as I was concerned,
what I was essentially doing was
criticizing a piece of legislation that
had not yet been passed,
but the university's legal department
decided that all that was sufficient for
them to distance themselves from me and
to engage in disciplinary activity.
So,
and then with regards to these human
rights tribunals where all of this stuff
would be sorted out,
it's like those places destroy your
reputation and destroy you financially
and can they put you in jail?
Well,
it's a complicated argument in some
sense,
but I can tell you that if you refuse to
pay the fine.
So that's the next step.
So I think you're being sold a bill of
goods here about how benevolent the
intent of bill see 16 is.
And I also know because another lawyer
told me that the,
because I suspected that the Ontario
Human Rights Commission,
people were behind all of this
legislation essentially speaking in
Canada and that that's actually the case
because the federal people have
indicated that these policies will be
interpreted,
interpreted in accordance with the
Ontario Human Rights Commission's
policies online.
And so you guys should go read those
because those are not fun.
And I would say that they pose an
incredible threat to your liberty and
it's all done under the guise of
compassion.
So like I don't consider myself a
particularly compassionate person,
let's say.
I think I'm more compassionate that I
should be for my own wellbeing.
But I can tell you that that is not the
only virtue.
And people who keep pushing that on you
are making a massive mistake and their
infant tantalizing you and they're
terrifying people in the university
community as you can tell by the letter
that I just read it and I've really,
I received dozens of letters like that.
People are afraid to say anything
because they're going to get targeted.
And if you wonder or not,
if that's true,
then just think about what happened to
me and ask yourself if it's true.
Good enough.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
So professor Bryson,
can we have you speak next and uh,
may I just say thank you for coming out
from Vancouver,
uh,
to join us.
Every,
everyone else here is from University of
Toronto,
but professor Bryson came out from
Vancouver,
so thank you.
Thank you,
provost Moran.
What a wild ride we're on this morning.
We're all doing okay so far.
I think as a Trinity College and Oil z
alumnus,
I'm typically delighted to return to the
University of Toronto.
Today is different to make sense of what
it means to be here today.
I've found myself going back frequently
to the 1989 debate at western on the
subject of race and Iq between Phillip
Rushton,
David Suzuki,
the stakes then and now we're very
familiar to borrow David Suzuki to
opening words on that day.
Quote,
I do not want to be here.
I do not want to dignify this man and
his ideas in public debate and quote
yesterday Bill See 16 passed third
reading in the House of Commons and
tomorrow is a trans day of remembrance.
If you only hear this,
know that I am unwavering in my belief
that the fundamental rights to safety
and the humanity of trans and non binary
people are not up for debate.
There was,
there was in 1989 at Western as now an
extraordinary media frenzy concerning
the apparent threat to academic freedom
posed by the mere possibility that
academic freedom is not an absolute
guarantee that has scholars our
relationship with knowledge and with the
public trust is tempered by
responsibilities and limitations of
crucial.
Important to my argument today is that
this is a relationship structured not on
juridical grounds.
This is not about the law but on ethical
grounds.
The very real effects of the knowledge
claims that we make as scholars require
that our claims be subjected to rigorous
critical scrutiny.
And there is no set of knowledge claims.
More important to subject to critical
scrutiny than statements that appear to
perpetuate and to insight already
existing forms of hatred,
violence,
and prejudice toward members of minority
groups.
We need to identify and address the
claims made in the recent public works
of Jordan Peterson claims about trans
people claims about the validity of
gender identity claims about the proper
use of pronouns and claims about
academic freedom rights.
And let's be clear,
we have a unique difficulty here today
in subjecting these claims to scholarly
scrutiny.
What kind of claims can you have?
An amateurish videos,
although this man is making these
claims,
has Dr. Jordan Peterson as a professor
and a clinical psychologist employed at
a great Canadian University.
The claims are not being made in
relation to any publicly accessible body
of peer reviewed scholarship.
So why this,
why now?
The recent public works of Jordan
Peterson provide a fabulous case study
of the cultural production of true
believers,
the cultural production of ignorance in
an age of reactionary populism,
the cultural,
a historian of cancer,
Robert proctor coined the term ag
natology to describe systematic
attention to the production of ignorance
and let's not beat around the bush.
Bad Science is deadly,
whether in the area of cancer or gender
and population health.
The cultural production of ignorance
does not point to a vacuum,
but rather represents a deliberate
relationship to knowledge that is
consequential in our lives.
For proctor,
the tactics used by the tobacco industry
provide a perfect example of how doubt
and controversy are enlisted to produce
ignorance.
So let's take a look at how
consequential and studied ignorance
works in relation to gender.
Here are the major claims of Dr
Peterson's recent public works.
Specifically the first of three lectures
concerning bill see 16 and I will quote
directly here from my lecture transcript
bill.
See 16 scares me lectures,
Dr. Peterson,
the Ontario Human Rights Commission is a
particularly pathological organization.
Social Justice Warrior types are
overrepresented and I can't help but
think it's because our current premier
is a lesbian and the lgbt community has
become extraordinarily good at
organizing themselves and has a fairly
pronounced and very,
very sophisticated radical fringe.
I'll carry on,
and I quote,
gender identity and gender expression
are not valid ideas.
They're not true.
There's no evidence for it.
I don't know what the options are if you
don't identify as a man or a woman.
There's an idea that there's a gender
spectrum.
I think it's an ill informed opinion and
quote rather than to address himself to
this scientific evidence concerning
gender identity and expression and by
adopting rhetorical strategies more
common to Breitbart news.com than a
university professors lecture.
Dr. Peterson goes on to discredit the
very constructs on political grounds
instead of on grounds provided by
scholarly evidence that these constructs
are in no particular order leftist
radical and politically correct on the
subject of pronouns and gender
expression.
Dr. Peterson is in phatic.
That quote,
I don't recognize another person's right
to determine what pronouns I use to
address them.
I won't do it.
For the vast majority of people.
He goes on to say gender identity and
sexual orientation and I guess he means
sex are the same thing.
And quote,
as for the definition of transgender,
Dr. Peterson claims that,
and I quote,
I don't believe that they,
these people,
these terms stand for good things.
I think that these people use these
terms as a pretense that they stand for
good things as a pretext for them to
continue their nefarious activities and
quote,
well,
this is hardly the stuff of academic
scholarship.
I'm a member of the global education
initiative of the World Professional
Association for transgender health and I
can tell you without a shred of doubt
that there is no link between the public
claims made by professor Jordan Peterson
about gender generally and transgender
specifically,
and a body of easily accessible peer
reviewed scholarship.
This body of peer reviewed research
knowledge provides conclusive evidence
that whereas anatomical sex is perhaps
dimorphic Lee categorical and that's
only if we choose to ignore intersects,
that secondary sex characteristics
cannot be argued simplistically to be
determined by Chromosomal sex and that
there is highly significant diversity in
gender identity and expression which
exists on a continuum that reveals
persistent differences that cannot be
explained by sex assigned at birth.
Gender identity and expression are
dynamic bio social aspects of human
diversity that are culturally and
socially in a complex relationship with
matter.
Gender identity and expression are
linked both to the extraordinary
plasticity of human life and the
fluidity of identity and as well.
And this is where we must pay close
attention linked to gender based
violence to minority stress and threats
to a whole host of rights in Canada that
are not up for debate here today.
These rights include the right to
recognition,
the right to communicability of
presence,
the right to culturally competent
institutional climates,
and perhaps the most profound of all
rights,
the right to safety and the right to
culture and access to knowledge.
Whereas almost all the media attention
on the Jordan Peterson affair has
focused on the possible threat to his
academic freedom.
I want to focus instead on the ethical
significance of an academic's total
dereliction of academic responsibility.
Academics are never free to distribute
totally bogus claims while trading on
the value provided by their title as a
professor in a great Canadian
University,
and perhaps even worse as a clinician
registered by an accreditation body,
quite the contrary,
every faculty member takes on academic
responsibilities that embody an ethical
commitment,
which is precisely not responsibilities
required by the law.
Academic knowledge that appears to
codify knowledge about minority
populations must not add to the harms
already facing minority groups by itself
contributing to the consolidation of
ignorance,
nor by inciting hatred toward members of
these groups.
Faced with Phillip Russians perpetuation
of racist assumptions in his research on
race and Iq in the 1989 debate,
David Suzuki concludes that one can only
infer quote.
He is either grossly ignorant or
deliberately mischievous.
Either way,
what is required is action by scientists
and academics.
His claims must be denounced.
This is not science and quote.
Surely the deliberate production of
ignorance concerning a precarious
minority group constitutes evidence of
the most unethical abnegation of the
responsibility of academics to
contribute to human wellbeing,
collective intelligence flourishing,
and the survival of planetary life.
The institution of the Public University
cannot and must not sanction ignorance.
And most emphatically we must denounce
the deliberate cultural production of
ignorance.
We can and we must do better and we must
do better.
Not because it is prescribed by the law,
but because we have an ethical
commitment to contribute to the
advancement of knowledge in a democratic
society.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
thank you all very much.
Um,
and so now I'm going to just ask a few
questions of clarification.
We'll go more or less in the order that
the speakers went.
And then as I indicated,
there are questions from the audience.
You can email them.
The address is there.
Um,
I think there are people in the room.
There we go.
There are a few people.
So put up your hands if you don't have a
capacity to email and they'll get around
to you.
We won't be able to ask,
answer all the questions some or post
them,
but we'll do our best.
Um,
so professor Peterson,
I'll start with you since you were the
first speaker.
Um,
of course there,
there are a few lawyers on the stage
here.
Law seems to figure very prominently in
your argument and in many of your
concerns.
And Professor Cossman is obviously set
out a number of the issues in terms of
what the laws to actually say.
You cited in response a number of legal
experts and one of the things about
legal experts as there are a lot of them
and they often don't agree.
Um,
but um,
in law we tend to between the law as it
is and the laws we would like it to be.
And the experts you cited seem to be
critical of the law as it is,
um,
along with you.
Um,
but does professors costs minutes
outlining of some of the elements of see
16 in particular,
does that give you any comfort?
Does that allay any of your concerns
that it really focuses on the advocacy
of genocide or the commission of hate
crimes?
And that those kinds of things are
probably the sort of restrictions that
most people in the room would think were
reasonable restrictions.
Okay.
No,
are you just give me any comfort.
Um,
and the reason it doesn't give me any
comfort is because as far as I'm
concerned,
what this is actually about has already
played itself out in my case.
And I already explained,
explained that to you.
Um,
I want to tell you some of the
pernicious things about the,
about the legislation and this is,
and she means see 16,
is that what you are actually,
I mean the policy guidelines that it
will be interpreted with him because the
legislation itself is only a couple of
paragraphs in it and it looks innocuous.
But you know,
I would say a,
a legal doctrine is something like a
virus and it has a life if you output,
we think if you,
if you let it go into a living system
that it propagates and it has effects
and the effects are a consequence of the
philosophy that's embedded inside the
law.
And if you really want to know about
this,
you should read Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn
school like archipelago.
Because what he does in that book is
tell you how the hypothetically humane
doctrines that were embedded in radical
Marxism at the end of the 18 hundreds
unfolded into Soviet society and
demolished it along with many other
societies.
I might,
I might point out 10.
He won the Nobel prize for that for no
small reason and was regarded as one of
the people who brought down the Soviet
Union.
And so it's a masterpiece.
That book,
and this is a complex issue,
and to understand it,
you have to do that sort of reading.
But I want to tell you a little bit
about what the law does.
And this is with regards to its
interpretation from the policy
guidelines.
It instantiates social constructionism
into our legal system.
You have to understand what that means.
There's a huge debate about how human
identity is,
is,
um,
uh,
upon what grounds human identity is
predicated.
Now the radical social constructionists
basically say that identity is nothing
but a social construction and not that's
in keeping with their philosophical
doctrines.
Partly Marxist and Parsley,
partly postmodern,
but that isn't,
and that was what I was objecting to
with regards to bill [inaudible] because
it insists,
do you understand this?
It makes this legal doctrine,
that biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression and sexual orientation
very independently and they don't.
Now the reason they don't is because 98%
of people,
it's 99.7% of people,
by the way,
at least with regards to the most
credible statistics have a gender
identity.
This essentially identical with their
biological sex and almost everybody who
is male and female by sex and gender
identity dresses that way.
And that's what gender expression
essentially is.
And then if you stack those three things
on top of each other,
they're basically isomorphic.
You can add sexual orientation to that
and 98% of people are heterosexual.
So the idea that those things very
independently is absolutely
preposterous,
but it's written into the law and that
has terrible consequences.
You see,
I don't know,
for example,
now to what degree,
any discussion in universities of the
biological differences between men and
women are legal and you think,
oh,
well that's an exaggeration.
It's like,
well,
I debated Nicholas Matte,
I believe that was his name.
A professor at the University of Toronto
on TV owes the agenda and he said,
write out for everyone to hear that the
scientific consensus is that there's no
biological differences between men and
women.
And I've received letters from people
who've told me that now the social
justice activist types are complaining
about the fact that the biologists
assign biological sex to animals because
it's only a social construct that we're
projecting onto their being.
And,
um,
you know,
we just heard that the co,
the chromosomal level of analysis is
complex.
It's not that complex.
What we have is a bi modal distribution
with a tiny number of exceptions in
that,
by the way,
is not a spectrum.
You see these words?
We're up.
You'll have other questions.
Nope.
Uh,
professor Cossman,
it just sort of picking up on some of
the,
uh,
items that Professor Peterson just
mentioned.
He was talking about social construction
is,
and then,
uh,
the idea that this is a very novel,
um,
issue when the law that like,
you know,
that the uh,
see 16 one of the concerns about it,
even if it isn't exactly,
um,
the specific provisions of the
legislation,
it's the fact that it's instantiating
this kind of social construction into
the realm of legal regulation.
Do you,
you're,
you're an expert in law.
Do you have any thoughts or comments
about that?
Um,
I think that any of us who are experts
in law would have something to say about
that.
Um,
the law has been regulating social
constructionism and social constructs
since there was law,
um,
language,
nationality,
religion,
citizenship,
family,
marriage.
There's no there,
there,
there are social constructs are social
constructs go to the very root of our
common law,
tradition,
property,
law,
okay,
sure.
Property exists.
It's there,
right?
But the idea that we own it,
the idea that we own property is
entirely socially constructed.
Um,
intangible property futures,
contingent liabilities.
Where are they?
I can't feel them.
I can't feel them there.
Where are they?
They're socially constructed.
These are the things that law regulates.
Um,
let me talk about one that you know,
that Professor Peterson is,
is quite fond
of.
Um,
the right to freedom of expression.
This is entirely a social construction
of the enlightenment.
It didn't exist before the
enlightenment,
um,
of humanism and of liberalism.
It depends on our understanding of
democracy.
It depends on our understanding of what
a right is.
a freedom is.
And it depends on our understanding of
what expression is.
The idea that the law regulates social
constructs is beyond irrelevant.
It doesn't tell us anything about good
social constructs and bad social
constructs.
It doesn't tell us anything about good
laws versus bad laws.
And one of the things that Professor
Peterson seems to misunderstand is this
difference between the law as it is and
the law as he might like it to be.
I have lots of disagreements with the
law as it is,
but what I've come and done here today
is explained to you what the law is
today and you might criticize it,
but that's just what the law is.
And it disturbs me profoundly that
Professor Peterson without arguments or
support has done effectively a post
truth claim on me.
He has basically said,
you're wrong.
There's no arguments,
there's no evidence,
there's no support.
That my description of what the law is
as a 30 year expert in this field is
simply wrong.
Um,
you know,
I don't think it's wrong.
I have some opinions on maybe how the
law ought to be,
but what I've done is I've common,
I've described how it is.
There's also I think a very important
distinction that's being missed here
about the penalties that are attached to
different laws.
Criminal laws involve imprisonment.
Civil laws involve damages and
restitution.
An Ontario Human Rights Commission
offense will result in a financial or a
non financial penalty such as rehiring
or training.
So what happens if a person refuses to
pay the fine?
You don't get to go to jail.
I'm sorry.
You don't.
Um,
the mechanisms of civil enforcement come
into effect.
The two most common forms of enforcing
judgements are seizure and sale of
assets.
And if your assets do not sufficiently
cover the fine,
then your wages will be garnished.
It's about money.
So yes,
it's true.
Your assets might be seized,
your income might be garnished,
but you don't get to go to jail.
Huh.
[inaudible]
um,
so we'll go back now to professor
Peterson cause there were two segments
that we've agreed that we,
we'd go back to him.
And actually I think you were just
starting at the end of your,
um,
of your discussion in your answer to the
last question to talk a little bit
about,
uh,
some of the points that professor Bryson
made your,
your picture of gender and,
and the relationship between sex and
gender in some of those issues.
And um,
you know,
she,
she lays out some of the science and
some of the actual scientific findings,
um,
around those,
around those issues.
And I wonder when you,
when you take a look at some of that
research,
does it,
how does it affect your,
your thinking on some of these questions
about,
in particular the point some people
think of as perhaps a rather simplified
picture of sex and gender
there.
Okay.
Well,
a couple of things.
The first thing I do,
I want to make a quick comment about,
um,
Dr Crossman's critique of my analysis
because she actually didn't address it.
I didn't say that the law shouldn't
regulate social constructions.
That's what the law does.
That's what she said.
That isn't what I said.
I said that the law now builds in a
social constructionist doctrine into the
fabric of the law.
That's not the same thing.
Obviously the law regulates property
rates in all of that and to some degree
those are social constructions,
although not to the degree that she
claims,
but this is a whole different thing.
This builds in a philosophy I've
identity and one of the things that
builds in for example,
is the claim that identity is only
subjectively defined and that's built
right in.
It says that your identity is whatever
you think it is.
Well,
let me tell you,
as a practicing psychologist,
that's absolute rubbish.
Your identity to look when,
when children are two years old,
that's what they think.
They think that their subjective reality
is everything.
And what you do is you socialize them
between the ages of two and four to
adopt an identity that's part of a
cultural negotiation.
It's like your identity as part of a
It's partly the game you play in partly
the game that I play with you and I have
to be a voluntary participant in that.
And not only,
not only is it not subjectively defined,
which detaches it entirely,
by the way,
from the underlying biological and the
underlying objective reality making any
claim you want for your subjective
identity.
Valid.
The other thing it does is,
um,
it did completely oblivious.
It's the idea that identity is actually
a Prac pragmatic entity for God's sake.
It's like if you're a lawyer or a father
or mother,
like an identity that has some solidity
to it,
say,
well,
for most lawyers anyways,
so I'm sorry I couldn't help it.
Your identity is also a vehicle within
which you traveled through life,
right?
It's a set of tools,
a set of pragmatic tools that you use to
interact with the social and the natural
world.
It's not only your subjective whim.
So,
okay.
And so with regards to the science,
it's like really,
you know,
I can give you just one example and oh
and I'll start with this and hopefully I
can do it quickly.
The idea of gender identity,
which is only defined subjectively in,
in the,
in the relevant law has been studied
intensively by personality psychologist
such as myself.
In fact,
my lab has done some of the,
I wouldn't say the most fundamental
research on it,
but you know,
we're in the boat and we're in the
ballpark.
Here's a little story.
Okay.
So the,
the differences between personality
between men and women are basically what
constitutes gender identity.
And in so far as it's not merely
subjective.
And one of the things that's happened is
that as the Scandinavian countries have
equalized their political and
sociological landscape,
the differences in identity between men
and women have got larger,
not smaller.
Do you understand that?
That's a refutation of the social
constructionist claim.
So what happens is that if you flatten
out the landscape so that there are very
few socioeconomic differences say,
or sociological differences in the
treatment between men and women,
what happens is the biological
difference maximizes,
it maximizes the understand that means
men and women get more different,
not more the same.
And the thing about women in the
audience,
bloody hell you should think about this
because don't you want to pursue the
things that you're interested in?
And if you pursue the things that you're
interested in,
cause you're interested in different
things than men,
I'm telling Ya.
And if you look at the interest,
if you look at the interest variation,
this has been established technically.
If you look at the interest variation,
there's almost no overlap between men
and women.
If you sum up the differences in
interest,
interest in temperament.
Okay.
No.
So I think that this provides perhaps a
good segway pat back to a professor
Bryson.
Um,
just to talk a little bit,
um,
uh,
but about some of the claims about in
particular,
um,
you know,
what,
what does some of the evidence,
what does some of the,
um,
whether it's sort of the objective
realities in this situation that we
might hold on to
one objective reality is what happens
when you stop reading.
So I'm going to recommend that for
anyone who's interested in a current
review of the literature on sex,
gender,
and gender differences,
that you take a look at Rebecca Jordan
Young or an fosto sterling who provide
extraordinary and very detailed reviews
of this literature.
And actually it comes down to the fact
that science about causality,
about in essence,
sex being linked and producing gender
requires us to move outside of the
current realm.
All we have in this realm is quite high
experimentation.
We can't actually do studies where we
manipulate the chromosome or the
hormonal environment.
And so since we can't remove sexism and
misogyny from the production of gender,
we can actually reach conclusions about
what we take to be gender differences.
And so although it plays really well on
the cover of people magazine,
brain sex,
or whatever,
a kind of arm chairs science that we
want to rely on for cocktail party Chit
Chat,
this is not the stuff of nature.
And by nature I don't mean something
that we take for granted.
I mean the peer reviewed academic
journal.
So it's really good to keep reading if
you're going to be employed at a great
Canadian university
point to pronouns.
Let's put pronouns in some kind of
context.
And I think it's really helpful in going
back to what Justice Minister Wilson
Raybould said yesterday,
following the passing of [inaudible] 16
and I'll quote,
it's our collective responsibility to
recognize and reduce the vulnerability
of Trans gender diverse person's to
discrimination,
hate crimes and hate propaganda.
And a lot of what we've been hearing
here is hate propaganda.
So what I want to say about pronouns is
that we have to get beyond this
simplistic discussion,
which is either about grammatical,
infelicity,
singular plural,
or that we should be nice to people.
We actually have to deal with our
responsibility in creating institutional
climates that take very seriously the
goal of reducing inequality.
That has always been the fundamental
goal of education.
So at the University of British
Columbia,
the trends to spirit and gender
diversity task force is looking at
everything in the context of what Greg
Bower and her amazing colleagues at
Trans Paul's call institutional and
informational eraser.
We are looking at housing,
student health,
how were trans and gender diverse
students going to go to student health
and get care that is both medically and
culturally competent.
How should we be organizing student
information systems so that people can
tell us their names and their pronouns?
This is a technical challenge only and
we have to rise to the challenge.
Okay,
thank you.
So now I know that there is much,
much more to say an ever,
but I have some questions from the
audience.
So I'd like to read those and,
and I'll try again,
uh,
just to divide up the time and the
questions are hopefully as fairly as
possible.
Um,
so professor Peterson,
let's start with you.
Uh,
so this question says,
you present your issue with bill,
see 16 to be that the infringement of
freedom of expression regarding gender
pronouns.
See as a problem.
Do you hold the same stance with other
discriminatory language and the human
rights code such as being able to use
racist terms with regard to students?
And if you believe that one of these
things is a violation but not the other
one.
Why?
I'm not sure I read that over all that
well,
but
okay.
So one,
one thing I would like to point out
before I answer that just so you will
notice is that I have in fact been
denounced today and what I am saying has
in fact described as hate propaganda.
So one thing I'd like to suggest to you,
every single person in the audience
you're next.
So keep it in mind.
All right.
So with regards to the question,
well first of all,
I don't think that these issues are the
same.
I don't think they're the same at all.
I mean,
I think being thinking about the pronoun
thing,
you know,
because one of the things that people,
uh,
it put me back on my heels for a while
because the claim was basically,
well,
it's something like why doesn't the mean
professor just play nice and,
and respect people by using their
pronouns?
And it took me like three weeks to
unpack that because who gets questioned
about Pronoun use?
I don't know why the hell I use the
pronouns I use,
I use them because they're part of the
language I use.
He and she,
because that's what everyone uses.
And so then I had to think about,
well why,
why do we in fact use pronouns?
And we use them in part for the same
reason that we use other categories.
And that's to simplify the world for
functional purposes.
Roughly speaking.
But then I was thinking,
well,
is the use of he and she a mark of
respect?
And the answer to that is,
well,
no,
it's not a mark of respect.
It can't be a mark of what you call 4
billion people.
Can't be a mark of respect.
Right.
It's,
it's a mark of basic categorization.
And so then the claim comes up,
well if someone wants you to use a
particular Pronoun,
then you're disrespecting them.
If you don't,
it's like,
hmm,
okay,
let's think that through a bit.
Well that assumes that when I'm using he
or she for,
for people and you know,
in normal parlance that I'm actually
indicating my respect for them.
And that's not true.
It's like if I don't know you,
I,
Claudius classify you generically and
basically I classify you in terms of how
you present yourself publicly.
I suppose that's your gender expression
and then I nail you with whatever
pronoun and seems to fit.
It has nothing to do with respect.
And besides that,
you bloody well don't get to demand my
respect.
Why should you,
you know,
I mean,
it's not like I respect everyone.
That's a foolish thing to do.
You respect people who were respectable.
You know,
you,
you make value distinctions between
people and that doesn't mean you
illegally discriminate against them.
Those aren't the same thing.
But I'm all for value judgments.
If,
if you don't buy value judgments,
then why bother learning anything?
Why,
why bother doing anything?
Why go from one point in your life to
another if the next point isn't better
in some manner?
So on telling me that I'm not respecting
people and I don't use their gender
pronouns.
And the other thing is I don't buy this
whole idea that the people who are
putting this legislation forward are
valid representatives of the Trans
community.
That's what they say they are.
We have mechanisms for deciding whether
someone's a valid representative of a
community and that generally involves
democratic voting.
I've received at least 20 letters from
transsexual people who are on my side
and by the way,
zero from others,
believe it or not,
who are perfectly happy with the idea of
gendered pronouns.
It's just they want to be the other one.
Now you can have a discussion about that
and there's lots of things to be said
about it,
but the idea that this community that's
coming out in these demanding rights is
somehow
representative of this homogenous dough
press minority,
I think is rubbish.
Well that leads us to our next
question.
Question.
I'm going to ask both the professor
cossman and professor Bryson to comment
on it.
Um,
so one of the objectives of the
transgender and queer rights movement is
to enter into public conscience in a
way.
And this person asks,
this can only occur through public
conversation.
Do you worry that it's,
it may not be possible to have
thoughtful discussion if there is
government restriction about this kind
of speech.
And do you worry that it would skew,
discuss discussion in one direction or
another?
Uh,
still perhaps.
So professor cossman first and then
professor Bryson.
Okay.
So I've spent a career being concerned
about the way in which,
um,
thoughtful discussion is often shut down
and I've been concerned about it on the
right,
I think concerned about it on the left
and I've been concerned about it in the
mushy middle.
And,
and I think that Professor Peterson has
actually performed some of this today
and so far as he just said that he was
denounced here today and that they're
going to come for you next.
So the thing is about speech is it
everybody gets it and you say something
and you then get criticized.
So professor Peterson hasn't been
denounced.
Some might want to,
um,
but he has been severely criticized and
that is actually what speech does.
That
is what speech does.
I think that,
um,
I think that there is an important way
to have public discussions,
um,
around a whole range of issues.
I would welcome a discussion on the role
of hate speech provisions.
I would welcome a discussion around the
role of hate speech and its
desirability,
um,
about whether the Supreme Court of
Canada is right or not right in
upholding its constitutionality.
But I would like to have that debate
with someone who is knowledgeable about
the law.
Thank you.
And Professor Bryson,
one of the big questions that I had to
deal with in considering whether or not
to accept a very generous offer,
a invitation of the University of
Toronto to come here today would be the
impact of this event on Trans and gender
non binary people,
uh,
specifically at the University of
Toronto and much more generally.
And so whereas I would say that I
recognize practices of peer review and
practices of peer review are not
denouncement practices of peer review,
our practices that we utilize to make
assessments about knowledge claims.
Whereas I would fully appreciate being
able to enter into a discussion about
gender and gender identity and issues
around trans culture as a means of
practicing peer review.
I think the difficulty that we've had
and we've managed to reproduce this
difficulty here today,
uh,
characterized just now by Dr. Peterson
as simplifying the world for functional
purposes,
simplifying the world for functional
purposes is not what I recognize to be
academic practice.
This is not how we relate to knowledge.
And so I think that there's a concern
when we don't subject claims that are
being made as knowledge claims by people
who carry titles at great Canadian
universities.
When we don't treat those knowledge
claims in the same way that we would in
any other field.
And when their knowledge claims made
about members of minority groups and
bottled vulnerable,
marginalized members of minority groups,
then I think that we all need to be very
concerned about how it is that we're
changing what we think we do in the
university,
which is supposed to be about the
advancement of knowledge and excellence.
Thank you.
Okay.
So it was sort of a slightly different
uh,
line,
but back to you,
Professor Peterson again from the
audience as a clinical psychologist,
refute it is Professor Peterson,
sorry.
As a clinical psychologist refusing to
acknowledge how damaging it could
potentially be to an individual to
disregard their identity.
Um,
the first thing I would like to say to
Mary Bryson is that this is an
invitation.
If she would like to debate,
if she would like to debate,
um,
the relationship between biology and
gender identity,
I'm extending her an invitation to do
so.
I'm sure that any number of student
groups would be more than happy to host
it.
And I'll put my knowledge of the peer
reviewed literature against her
knowledge.
Here we go to the question though.
Um,
identities,
a very complicated thing and you know,
when I engage in clinical discussions
with my clients,
it's all about their identity.
And so the idea that it's a very
difficult question to even engage with
because I don't understand it's,
I don't understand it.
It makes things so simple that you can't
discuss them properly.
All I do in my clinical practice and I
have about 20,000 hours of experience
with clinical in my clinical practice
and I've dealt with all sorts of people,
far more variation people than the
typical person ever encounters.
And I think I've done it at least
reasonably competently all my
discussions with people in my clinical
practice or about their identity,
given the definition of identity that I
brought forth,
how they feel about themselves,
how they conceptualize themselves.
Cause those are two different things.
How that plays out in their interactions
with other people and what the
functional significance of that isn't
arm I'm going to save forthrightly.
Well two things.
One is that I don't believe that any of
my clients have had cause to worry about
my interpretation of their identity.
Because what I do in my practice is help
them discover what that is.
I'm really,
I'm seriously not interested in imposing
any ideas of identity onto someone.
It's because I don't,
I can't do that.
I don't know what the right vehicle is
for you to travel through life.
What I can help you do is articulate
your concerns.
I can ask you questions where I see
contradictions in yourself.
Articulation.
I can help you make plans for the
future.
And I've helped thousands and thousands
and thousands of people by the way,
make plans for the future with the stuff
that I do online.
And so I'm helping people build a
genuine identity.
Um,
well,
and that's what I do.
So that's the answer to that question
and I think I do it well.
I mean in the stuff we've done from a
research perspective with the future
authoring program,
which I offered to people free and week
and a half ago,
to help them catalyze their identities.
We've helped 5,000 university students
increase their grade point average 20%
and decrease their dropout by the same.
And the biggest effect have it's been
with men and,
and non Western ethnic minority students
who've accelerated their performance up
beyond the range of the normal for the,
for the dominant culture,
a pure psychological intervention,
I might say,
a a sociological intervention.
So I'm perfectly willing to stack my
record on identity formulation up
against anyone so and so,
and I should also point out,
I think where I'm most vulnerable in
this entire debate and I expect this
will happen and you know,
there's already been noise about it on
the Ontario Psychological Association
website.
I think they'll,
that they'll probably come after my
clinical license so that,
that'd be my,
that'd be my guess.
So.
So
I think we might be straying a little
away from your question.
No.
So,
uh,
just uh,
thank you.
Um,
so
no,
we're doing because that,
that question
question involved my clinical practice,
I'm not straying a bit that involve my
clinical practice.
And there was a reason that the question
was posed.
So I'm not straying.
Thank you.
Um,
the next question concerns how a free
and democratic society is,
uh,
how that idea is developed in this is I
guess particularly our for Professor
Cossman.
So you mentioned that,
um,
the uh,
freedom of expression and the
antidiscrimination equality provisions
of the charter are balanced through
section one,
which explicitly it's section one starts
out our charter.
Um,
and it has this idea of free and
democratic society.
So how,
how is that idea established and who was
part of that discussion?
So the language of section one is that
all rights and freedoms contained in the
charter are subject to such reasonable
limits as are demonstrably justifiable
in a free and democratic society.
So like,
I didn't write those right?
Wasn't me.
Um,
it was a whole bunch of folks back in
the late seventies and the early 1980s
where there was a constitutional
committees that decided what the
Canadian constitution would be.
It was parliament,
it was the Senate,
it was all the provinces with the
exception of Quebec of course.
Um,
that came to an agreement that the
constitution would be our highest form
of law.
And it's also important,
there's a,
there's a lot of misunderstanding around
the constitution.
So the constitution only restricts
government action.
It is not what's at play here in terms
of uh,
universities.
In fact,
the charter doesn't actually apply to
universities.
Human rights codes do,
but the charter does not.
Um,
and so the courts from the very early
times of when the Supreme Court of
Canada,
when it had to start interpret all the
charter rights,
there's section two B,
that's freedom of expression.
There's freedom of religion.
There's the right to be free from
unreasonable search and seizure.
There's the right to life,
liberty and security of the person.
There's the right to equality.
Before the law,
the Supreme Court of Canada developed a
test whereby it said it was going to
figure out how to balance rights.
And so if you have a violation of
section two be freedom of expression,
which is,
which is quite a low bar,
anything that restricts speech is
considered to be a violation of that,
right?
You then move to section one and the
court in a very early case called the
oaks case,
developed a test whereby it,
it does that balancing first it looks to
see whether there are any pressing and
substantial objectives in the government
legislation that actually is limiting
those rights.
It then looks at if there are pressing
and substantial objectives and often in
the context of hate speech,
for example,
that is about preventing discrimination,
but there's many others as well.
Um,
it then looks to see whether the
violation of the speech is proportionate
to the pressing and substantial
government objective.
And there are many,
many legal steps along the way here.
It's complicated.
There are lots of steps and it is the
Supreme Court of Canada that does this.
It is the Supreme Court of Canada that
defines and ultimately decides how we
balance those rights.
Thank you.
Um,
so another question for Professor
Peterson.
Um,
why do you feel that someone's personal
gender identity and pronouns infringes
your free speech?
Can one not also argue based on your
interpretation that professors can use
racial slurs in their classroom?
Um,
and the,
that the inability to do
so would violate their freedom of
speech?
Well,
that's pretty much the same question.
I think.
Um,
I think that we're crossing a dangerous
line and the line is the requirement
that's being put upon people by
government agencies with the full force
of the law behind them to decide what
language categories you're going to use.
Now,
I think that's a form of compelled
speech,
which has a technical meaning.
I know in the United States the American
Supreme Court ruled against the
government's,
right?
Do you use compelled speech in 1943 I
understand that this isn't the United
States,
but we share a common law background and
the doctrines are relevant.
Um,
for me,
you see,
when I opened this debate,
this forum,
um,
I tried to explain what this is about
and I couldn't explain everything and
that it's about,
because it's about too many things.
But one of the things,
it's about his etiology and the
distinction between the left and the
right.
And let's say now I truly believe that
these made up pronouns of which there
are many dozens in fact and there's no
consensus on them and that doesn't even
begin to start a discussion about the
use of the other kin pronouns.
And you can look those up if you want.
Because if you can define your identity
subjectively any way you want,
then there's absolutely no reason that
you can't claim a non human identity.
And you may not know.
But in the lgbt a rainbow coalition,
there is q plus and the q plus people
include the other kids who claim a non
human identity and they're arguing in
that rainbow coalition that they have
the same right to their,
um,
to their pronouns that everyone else
does.
And their pronouns includes such things
as work worms self.
You're not supposed to interrupt.
Actually,
I was just going to ask if you could go
back to the point about the analogy
between,
uh,
the racial slur and the end.
I don't think there's any analogy at
all.
But the thing about difference between,
I'm talking about compelled speech,
there's a difference between saying that
there's something you can't say and
saying that there are things that you
have to say.
And I regard these made up pronouns,
all of them as the neologisms of a
radical pc authoritarians.
Do you understand that?
And I don't,
I'm not a fan of that sort of person.
And the reason I'm not a fan of that
sort of person is because I've done my
homework,
I've read everything I can get my hands
on in the development of authoritarian
political systems and I know the
literature inside out and backwards.
And I am not going to be a mouthpiece
for language that ID test.
And that's [inaudible].
So we have one question left and I'm
going to what end?
It's for professor Bryson.
Professor Bryson.
Um,
I noticed that you were on the vice
presidential task force at UBC for a two
spirited trans and other folks.
And I wonder,
this is obviously been a difficult
debate for the University of Toronto,
but from your perspective as someone who
salt.
So had a senior leadership role as well
as being an expert in the area.
Do you have any thoughts or guidance
about what universities can do to ensure
that we're moving things forward in a
helpful,
inclusive boy?
Let's talk about
[inaudible].
So this week we heard from uh,
Justin Trudeau's government about the
apology that would meet be made to Lgbq
Canadians concerning,
uh,
the extraordinarily violent impacts of
discriminatory activities that were also
research activities happening,
uh,
at Canadian universities and elsewhere
to locate and to fire lgb Canadians from
the public service and from the rcmp.
And let's pay attention to some of the
details of that situation.
You can google the fruit machine and an
incredibly bogus apparatus that was
created,
let's say not coincidentally by a
psychologist at Carleton University Dr
Wake,
who was the chair of the psychology
department intended only to identify,
uh,
supposedly homosexuals who then would be
fired from government service and from
the rcmp.
Those actions were carried out by means
in part of entirely bogus research
claims supported and funded by a
Canadian public university,
Carleton University.
If we fast forward to the fairly recent
past,
we could look at chem h making an
apology for the incredibly damaging work
carried out by Zucker in his focus
conversion therapy based entirely on
these ideas about sex producing gender
constancy,
which then in the case of gender diverse
young people could be cured by means of
conversion therapy.
Cam H had to apologize to the Canadian
public and to Ontarians for the harms
carried out by Dr Zucker.
And so I think that we might need to
think about two things at the University
of Toronto.
And one would be an apology for any,
uh,
damages to the right to safety and the
right to humanity on the part of Trans
and gender diverse people at the
university and in the great city of
Toronto more generally.
And then of course,
the University of Toronto.
And perhaps it already is.
And I'm sure you know more about this
than I do,
could implement the kind of wide ranging
program to think very carefully about
how in an intelligent way to accommodate
gender diversity and Trans people in
this wonderful,
great Canadian University that is the
University of Toronto.
Thank you.
We are,
we are at the
end of our time.
Um,
I would like to thank all the
participants,
the organizers,
the many,
many,
many staff who did a great job making
this forum happen.
And of course,
uh,
the members of the audience who came out
today,
I don't so like to acknowledge,
and I think professor Bryson mentioned
this,
that tomorrow,
November 20th is transgender day of
remembrance and that observes the fact
that many,
uh,
who many members of the transgender
community,
uh,
either lost their lives or were injured
in acts of violence.
And on a moment like this,
it's worth remembering that the reason,
the legislation we're debating today and
we're discussing today came into
existence,
was to protect those communities from
those acts of violence.
The five,
19 at five 19 church street has a number
of activities and the U of t sexual and
gender diversity office also does.
Um,
it's a,
it's,
I wasn't sure what to expect today,
I have to say coming in as moderator.
But,
uh,
I just want to thank everyone once again
for the discussion and hope as we said,
that some illumination has happened,
which is after all of what we seek to do
in the university.
Thank you.
[inaudible].